Let's smash this s**t.
Smash.
One, two, three.
Cheers.
Cheers history.
Did you know I was Jewish?
I didn't until tonight.
Chug this.
Chug this?
Meow. Meow.
They gave us our dream.
City of angels.
Yes, sir.
I hate you.
Let's solve every murder.
Noroc shesa shasate.
Congrats!
Congrats?
To rats.
Cheers.
Yes. This is sex.
To Joan.
Still got it,
after all these years.
Oh my god, are you kidding?
What? Isn't that
what we were doing?
I love...
No, no, no, I love it.
To siblings.
Woo! Ella Fitzgerald,
my baby girl.
To kids.
Cheers to the kids.
To every naut.
Cosmonauts and astronauts.
To space.
To underdogs.
To the Brooklyn.
Ugh, god, the Middle Ages.
I'm glad we're not in them.
Amen.
Times are tough,
but not Middle Age tough.
Uh-uh, not Middle Ages tough.
To Mr. Rogers.
And the good of humanity.
Amen.
Scoundrels.
To scoundrels.
To inventors.
To everybody.
To literally everybody.
Cheers.
Jesus Christ.
And that's the end. Cheers.
Cheers.